battled new york governor andrew cuomo
says he will not resign
over sexual harassment allegations but
he is apologizing
to anyone he offended and he says he's
embarrassed by the uproar
his critics say he hasn't yet apologized
to the 15
thousand plus families who lost loved
ones in nursing homes
in new york after his orders
correspondent brian yennis has details
tonight from brooklyn good evening brian
good evening brett tonight new york
governor andrew cuomo apologized more
than a dozen times in his first coveted
19 on camera briefing
since the sexual harassment allegations
came to light the governor
beginning his comments by saying his
lawyers told him not to speak today
but he did anyway
i'm not going to resign new york
governor andrew cuomo
is refusing to step down but he is
apologizing amid
accusations of sexual misconduct by
three women
i apologize today i will apologize
tomorrow i will apologize the day after
the governor contrite and seemingly
emotional as he indirectly addressed the
claims
it was unintentional and i
truly and deeply apologize for it
i feel awful about it
and frankly i am embarrassed
by it last week former aide lindsey
boylan accused the governor of unwanted
touching
saying cuomo kissed her in his office i
never touched anyone
inappropriately another former aide
charlotte bennett says cuomo made
inappropriate sexual remarks
that made her feel quote horribly
uncomfortable
i never knew at the time i was making
anyone feel uncomfortable and about this
photo in the new york times that 33 year
old anna ruxed
shows governor cuomo asking her if he
could kiss her while touching her face
at a 2019 wedding
it is my usual and customary way
of greeting what i also understand
is it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
my intent lawyers agree
there's the jury of public opinion that
is who he is appealing to
here he is appealing to the people of
new york and the people of this nation
in the hopes that his feelings matter
and maybe they do to that jury but under
the law they do not
both former aides criticized cuomo's
news conference today
boylan tweeting how can new yorkers
trust you governor to lead our state if
you don't know when you've been
inappropriate with your own staff
bennett released a statement through her
attorney reading in part the governor's
press conference was full of falsehoods
and inaccurate information
the governor now asking new yorkers for
patience as new york's attorney general
leticia james
oversees an independent investigation
wait
for the facts from the attorney
general's
report before forming an opinion
now under state law governor cuomo is
entitled to receive updates on the a.g
investigation in fact
he signs the checks that fund it
meanwhile there was no mention today of
the nursing home scandal of which his
administration is reportedly
under an fbi investigation in fact
nearly a year later and still no direct
apology
from the governor to those nursing home
victims families who believe his
policies
may have led to some unnecessary deaths
brett
hey brian there weren't even questions
about the nursing home controversy were
there
no no there were not brett okay brian
yeah brooklyn thanks